[Musique]
pour tous
bonsoir à tous et ravi de vous retrouver
pour un nouveau numéro du sky échos le
récit de la vie des acteurs économiques
de saint quentin en yvelines
pour débuter cette émission nous sommes
dans une rue commerçante de montigny le
bretonneux des centres-villes impactés
par ce second confinement est
bouleversée au cours de cette émission
en attendant voici le sommaire de ce
cinquième numéro du sky ico c'est le
nouvel outil pour développer le commerce
de proximité saint-quentin-en-yvelines
lance shopping sky une application de
vente des produits locaux avec le second
confinement certains commerces dits non
essentiels sont contraints de fermer sur
décision administrative
ils tentent de s'adapter à la situation
nous sommes allés les rencontrer
enfin la région ile de france propose de
chèques numérique depuis 2010 9 une aide
pour permettre aux tpe et pme de faire
leur transformation digitale saint
quentin en yvelines au soutien de ces
commerçants durant le premier
confinement l'agglomération a créé cette
page facebook sky soutient ces
commerçants un groupe qui rassemble plus
de 4500 membres et sur lequel vous
retrouvez les initiatives des
commerçants saint quentinois
l'agglomération a aussi créé cette carte
interactive qui rassemble l'ensemble des
magasins ouverts ainsi que leur
fonctionnement est une nouvelle étape va
être franchie avec le lancement de
l'application shop in sky un marketplace
dédié aux produits saint quentinois les
détails dans ce décryptage
[Musique]
elle permet pour les clients d'avoir
dans leur poche l'ensemble des dirait
des commerces de saint quentin et pour
les commerces d'être en contact
effectivement d'être une boutique en
ligne en quelque sorte d être en contact
avec leurs oeufs avec leurs clients
c'était une idée qui qui existait depuis
quelques mois mais dans le contexte
actuel vous pouvez comprendre qu'on a
accéléré le processus parce que c'est
une aide indispensable à l'heure
actuelle aux clients parlent beaucoup à
l'heure actuelle du cri comme en
collecte bien et c'est cela d'une
certaine façon c'est cela et c'est
mettre à disposition des commerçants une
application qui est une application
gratuite pour eux et qui va permettre en
principe de les aider dans la période
actuelle
[Musique]
d
certains sont dits non essentiels
d'autres peuvent rester ouverts les
commerces du territoire font face à
différentes situations
mais ils savent s'adapter face à la
crise sanitaire nous sommes allés
recueillir leurs témoignages dans trois
centres villes saint quentinois partons
en immersion chez les commerçants de
saint quentin en yvelines
pour commencer cette immersion nous
sommes aux clayes-sous-bois nous nous
rendons à la boutique secret d'intérieur
spécialisé dans la vente de décoration
pour la maison
contraint de fermer avec ce second
confinement dominique duguet sa gérante
a dû s'adapter venez on va la rencontrer
[Musique]
bonjour dominique duguet bonjour nicolas
bienvenue chez sacre d'intérieur
merci de nous accueillir dans votre
boutique
vous êtes actuellement sur un
fonctionnement click and collect ring
comment ça se passe que dans quelle
situation vous êtes la situation du
magasin va très bien en fait après le
premier confinement on a récupéré tout
notre chiffre d'affaires les clients
étaient très nombreux à venir
bon maintenant par contre la situation
est catastrophique le mois de novembre
le mois de décembre sont des chiffres
énormes on n'est pas du tout du tout
dans la même situation qu'au premier
continent c'est bien plus grave
comment vous vous êtes adapté du coup
face à cette situation eh bien on a fait
un site très très rapidement en trois
jours on a mis six cent cinquante
produits sur le net on avait pas de site
de vente on a travaillé j'ai deux
alternances qui travaillent avec moi
plus ma famille on s'est tous mis à
terre ce fameux site et donc deux
cuillères nous faisons le click and
collect du coup la digitalisation c'est
quelque chose que vous avez mis en place
par rapport à la situation
oui oui on va travailler sur le net
c'est parce que j'aime moins ce qui nous
ce que je veux faire c'est le contact
client sait conseiller mes clients les
recevoir dans mon magasin
mais vu la situation catastrophique je
me suis mis très vite sur internet
alors comment ça s'est passé vous pouvez
nous expliquer comment vous avez mis en
place des choses et puis vous avez aussi
dit quelque chose d'innovant en place
oui alors tout d'abord j'ai beaucoup
communiqué sur les réseaux sociaux pour
annoncer que j'allais faire un site
internet mais alternant mon mari et moi
même on s'est mis à récupérer toutes les
photos chez les fournisseurs
on est venu faire des photos dans le
magasin et on a tout installé sur le
site
donc c'est très très long parce qu'il
faut donner les désignations des
produits les prix etc
et c'est très très long alors
l'innovation alors là j'y tiens vraiment
à tout le monde connaît les bizuths
apéro moi je vais faire le visio
shopping et je commence dès aujourd'hui
à faire un jogging
en fait le but le client est chez lui
très
installé très confortablement et moi je
lui présente tous les produits en visio
ils me demandent ce qu'ils souhaitent et
en fonction de ses besoins
je répond à ces questions c'est ma vie
le magasin c'est ma vie et donc j'ai
vraiment vraiment envie de continuer à
travailler dans ce magasin merci
dominique duguet avec plaisir et pour
permettre la digitalisation de ce type
d'activité la région ile de france
propose depuis 2010 9 le chèque
numérique une aide financière pouvant
atteindre 1500 euros objectif permettre
aux commerçants et aux artisans
d'utiliser les outils numériques dans
leurs activités
les détails avec alexandra dublanche la
vice présidente en charge du
développement économique au conseil
régional d'ile-de-france et nous on se
retrouve juste après à montigny le
bretonneux pour poursuivre notre
immersion auprès des commerçants saint
quentinois chimérique
il a été créé en fin 2018 pour aider les
commerçants à ceux numérisés et à être
plus compétitifs notamment par rapport à
tout commerce en ligne et les grandes
surfaces
[Musique]
peut être de la création d'un site
internet de la publicité digitale
s'appelle les abonnements à des
marketplace de la formation au numérique
comme je le disais puisqu'on l'a étendu
pendant le premier confinement ça peut
être également des frais de livraison
donc voilà c'est assez vaste et on
s'adapte au fur et à mesure des besoins
que leur remontée à la fois les
commerçants et les restaurateurs notable
[Musique]
se rendre sur le site de la région et
donc il ya ce chèque numérique que vous
trouverez donc vous pouvez candidate et
après fournir les factures et toucher un
maximum de 1500 euros faut savoir que ça
ne finance pas 100 % des dépenses ça
c'est les financements publics on va
jusqu'à 50 % des dépenses
là on voit d'ailleurs d'un intérêt pour
ce dispositif puisque on a dix fois plus
de demandes au quotidien que par rapport
à avant
[Musique]
pour les communes qui voudrait lancer un
mouvement de mouvements un peu plus
vaste pour au sein de leur ville pour
tous leurs commerçants pour créer des
marques plein local nous à la région
valérie pécresse on les accompagne par
le volet 2 du chèque numérique on a
lancé récemment qui va jusqu'à 10000
euros sachant qu'une plateforme locale
comme ça de vente au niveau d'une
commune ça coûte entre 20 et 40 pour
cette seconde étape direction la société
à votre service traiteur spécialisé dans
le service de restauration auprès des
particuliers et des entreprises
jean-marc the do et ses équipes
continuent de travailler malgré la
réduction de son activité
suivez moi je crois que sont cuisinés
est en train de préparer des pigeons
pour la semaine prochaine c'est parti et
nous sommes avec jean-marc se noue
bonjour bonjour
[Musique]
vous êtes le dirigeant de la votre
service traiteur société immtel créé il
ya 15 ans alors on sait que le secteur
de la restauration est frappé par ce
second confinement comment ça se passe
pour vous et bien déjà nous ça a été
stoppée dès le couvre-feu nous
travaillons énormément avec les
entreprises et les particuliers dans
l'événementiel tout toute l'année là ça
totalement arrêtée on a eu une quinzaine
d'annulations des l'annnonce du
couvre-feu et quand est arrivé le
confinement
las tout s'est arrêté plus aucune
commande tout ce que l'on avait été
annulé donc il a fallu penser à à faire
autrement on voit que vous avez quand
même un peu d'activité là où votre
cuisine et préparer des pigeons tout à
fait alors on a des clients on a la
chance d'avoir des clients fidèles
depuis 15 ans qu'ils nous ont demandés
d'affaires des petits menus pour les
anniversaires ou là entre autres pour un
anniversaire de mariage
heathrow 3 et vous demandez un menu un
petit peu spécial on a donc préparé des
pigeons du foie gras que l'on va mettre
à la carte la semaine prochaine
puisqu'on a mis en place une carte de
vente à emporter qui va changer tous les
mardis donc là dès la semaine prochaine
y aura du pigeon il y aura du foie gras
pour les menus et c'est là où vous avez
réinventer en quelque sorte notre
activité parce que finalement vous êtes
habitué à travailler pour des
particuliers des entreprises plutôt dans
l'événementiel mais là vous allez
devenir quasiment un restaurant à vente
à emporter en fait c'est ça on a
l'habitude nous de d'avoir des commandes
quelques jours avant voire quelques
semaines avant d'avoir des commandes
pour vingt trente quarante cinquante
personnes
là je vous dis pour dimanche c'est pour
trois personnes demain on a des
plusieurs petites commandes de 2 3
personnes
c'est totalement se réinventer c'est
entre faire du 40 50 cents personnes et
faire deux par deux merci jean marc
denault merci à vous
[Musique]
dernière étape dans ce centre
d'esthétique à voisins le bretonneux
épilation minceur et anti âge cet
institut est dirigée par nathalie puig
elle a dû cesser son activité du fait du
second confinement mais a néanmoins
maintenu la vente de produits à distance
c'est parti on va l'avoir
[Musique]
nathalie pic bonjour bonjour
dirigeante de ce centre d'esthétique zen
institut alors comment ça se passe pour
vous eh bien ça se passe que je suis
fermé depuis vendredi matin 30 octobre
une que je ne pratique plus aucune
prestation auprès de ma clientèle et du
coup quelles conséquences ça peut avoir
conséquence directe baisse du chiffre
d'affaires au moins 70 % puisque c'est
ce que représente mes prestations
et face à cette situation comment vous
est adapté alors je me suis adapté à la
vitesse de l'éclair puisque le week-end
dernier j'ai créé une boutique en ligne
que j'ai mis en service dès lundi matin
pour que les clientes puissent acheter
en click and collect elle commande sur
mon site internet
elle paye et j'organise des rendez-vous
pour qu'elles viennent chercher à la
porte de l'institut leurs produits vous
avez beaucoup d'attentes ça va être une
réussite
cette nouvelle stratégie entre
guillemets alors j'ai beaucoup
d'attendre parce que finalement il faut
toujours tirer le meilleur des plus
mauvaises situations si ça fonctionne
j'espère faire perdurer cette cette
fonctionnalité de vente avec les canes
collecte en plus de la vente en magasin
lorsque je serai réouvert merci nathalie
pays avec plaisir dirigeante de zen
institut
[Musique]
c'est la fin de ce numéro merci de nous
avoir suivis et mission à revoir en
replay sur notre site internet ou sur
l'application mobile tv 78 à bientôt
pour un nouveau numéro du sky est faux
[Musique]
m